[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with whitehall
editor at the financial times sebastian
payne and the deputy political editor at
the daily telegraph lucy fisher they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
the eyes headline looks at new year's
eve celebrations going ahead as sajid
javid said there will be no restrictions
before 2022.
the daily telegraph focuses on a new
year's eve without restrictions as the
public is still urged to remain cautious
despite the latest data showing that
omicron may be a milder variant
and the times also leads with the
government ruling out fresh restrictions
ahead of the new year
the guardian reads england goes it alone
as it becomes the only uk nation not to
impose stricter coveted measures
post-christmas
where's the pm is the headline in the
mirror in reference to a record number
of covet cases in england recorded on
christmas day
the daily express headline draws
attention to the warning of an energy
boss who says energy bills could double
the daily star reads happy new beer as
temperatures are set to rise
for new year's day
and tonight i'm joined by sebastian
payne and lucy fisher welcome
to you both let's start off by having a
look at the telegraph
and that story in many of the other
papers the fact that there will be no
new restrictions over the new year's
period and certainly not until 2022
sebastian
yes boris johnson examined the latest
colonel virus data today in a meeting
with chris whitty england's youth
medical officer and other scientific and
medical advisors and came to the
conclusion there was nothing new that
meant they would need to bring in
further restrictions and that means
essentially new year's plans will go
ahead as they would have otherwise in
england which is a stark contrast to the
other three nations of the united
kingdom where rules have come in over
the past couple of days on big
gatherings on nightclubs and on
distancing indoors and we've heard from
sanji javid the health secretary today
who essentially said he will be cautious
take a lateral flow test celebrate
outside you can although wherever i am
it's pretty chilly and i don't think
anyone would like to do that but
fundamentally boy johnson is keeping the
same course he decided last week that 3d
ever since the omicron wave has taken
off and hospitalizations have risen in
london boris johnson has tried to play
this delicate balance of do you make
restrictions quicker and faster to avert
a christ later or do you sort of hang
tight and hope it'll come out all right
and in the other three nations of the uk
those leaders have decided to act
quicker and bring in those restrictions
as cases continue to soar
hospitalizations are rising but boris
johnson has gone a different way and i'm
sure celebrated people across the whole
of england will be delighted at this but
it remains to be seen if we come to
january in two or three weeks if
hospitals are under pressure across the
country will the prime minister have
made that right decision well his
ministers will think so his mps will i'm
not sure the nhs might think uh the
prime minister should have maybe put
some extra restrictions in at this point
yes lucy going it alone he seemingly is
taking a huge gamble or he's very
certain that the stats the data is
really what's leading him in this
direction
well i think we have to put this in
context there has only been confirmation
so far that new year's eve can go ahead
without restrictions i think there is
very much a warning and almost a hint
perhaps from sajda javed today that in
january more moves could possibly be
expected i think the news today is good
for revelers it's good for tory mps who
are skeptical of further lockdown
measures and of course it's good for
hospitality bosses a sector that's been
among the hardest hit during the
pandemic but as sebastian said you know
there are worries among medics and among
scientists
and certainly warnings coming from the
nhs
about the thousands of members of staff
who are off sick leading to additional
strain on the health service at this
time of year but so far what boris
johnson has reviewed today is the
pre-christmas data that shows that
hospitalizations are around a half of
what they were last year while the
number of reported covert cases are
almost three times so that just shows
how far we've come with the vaccine
program also the news today that 12 000
so-called jingle jabs vaccinations took
place on christmas day itself so the
booster program rollout continues
will it be enough to keep us without
restrictions in january it is unclear
and as as we've sort of said you know
look to the rest of the united kingdom
where there are curbs on indoor mixing
some further measures in scotland such
as limits on the number of sports fans
allowed into stadiums across europe many
more restrictions it could be that we
yet see some further measures coming in
the new year
yes but up until that point the health
secretary as the eye is covering the
story of no further restrictions before
2022 the health secretary is saying that
that is the case but in the same breath
also saying they're looking at the the
daily data so how can he be so certain
that there will be no restrictions
before 2022.
sebastian
well i think at the moment nobody's
certain of anything and of course that's
the thing everybody just wants in their
lives to know what can they do tomorrow
next week next month and due to covert
generally but also particularly the
rapid spread of omicron that is not
something and politicians can
particularly say here now when that
crucial decision was made last when the
cabinet met and boris johnson went into
that meeting actually minded towards
bringing restrictions but then they had
a two and a half hour i think it was
cabinet meeting where the vast majority
of ministers made the case against only
three members of the cabinet said that
they would favor restrictions at that
point the basis that downing street is
operating on is the data has to look
worse for restrictions to come in so if
things continue as they are then they
are hoping they can battle through this
the nhs will cope hospitals won't be
overwhelmed and despite those
eye-watering infection numbers that are
still continuing to rise
hospitalizations as lucy was just saying
are nowhere near where they were last
year the vaccines plus the natural
immunity we've developed over the past
12 months me are in a totally different
position but i think the fact is there
is still this question of
can hospitals cope can the nhs code
because that's what restrictions are
about now because we know the way to
stop serious illness from coronavirus is
jabs and that's what's still going very
well in this country at the moment i
love the idea of 12 000 people getting
up on christmas morning sort of opening
a stocking go running down to their gp's
clinton to get a job but that just shows
how enthusiastic people are for these
sort of things but fundamentally i don't
think anyone in westminster really knows
that taking on a day-by-day week-by-week
basis will hear more from the government
next monday if the situation looks worse
and it could be entirely different and
england could follow the rest of the uk
but if it's the same as it is now then i
think it will just continue
yeah we read in the guardian lucy that
scientists have been critical of the
decision by england not to bring in
further restrictions saying it was the
moment of the greatest divergence
between scientific advice and
legislation seen since the start of the
pandemic that is slightly worrying isn't
it
well it's a worry for boris johnson
certainly if the data does get worse in
coming days uh and in hindsight he's
seen to have made a misstep here i think
he is stuck in a hard place you know in
that final week of parliament before it
rose for the christmas recess suffering
the worst back bench rebellion of his
career as 101 tory mps rebelled against
the covered passports measure and really
brought home to him just how fed up they
are with covid restrictions on the other
hand scientists who have often been
urging the government to go further
and be over cautious in the eyes
of some mps
it's difficult for the prime minister to
balance that i do think at the moment on
the basis of the data that's publicly
available it does seem to be that it
could be over cautious for the prime
minister to be going further any further
immediately and curbing new year's eve
restrictions given that it seems the nhs
is not
under immediate threat of collapse which
has always been the great worry here but
yes i think he will be work he will be
concerned he will be nervous he's been
accused of acting too slowly many times
in the past too slow to shut the borders
previously too slow to lock down the
country i think he will be monitoring it
day by day and things could change
quickly after december 31st if the data
dramatically worsens the responsibility
in the onus seemingly is being put back
on the public with the health secretary
saying that people should take steps
themselves to protect others that the
government won't be taking any further
measures um it's back in the
the course of the the public
that's very much the way the government
has painted this ever since we had
freedom day back in july was to see
people look the government us we are not
going to dictate life to you're going to
have to live with this thing now
obviously they've pulled back from that
approach due to the very rapid spread of
the omicron variant but i think just to
pick up on that point you mentioned
before about ministers versus scientific
advice that we know from those leaked
management sage which is the committee
of the government's scientific advisors
that they had a broad consensus around
more measures but you've got to remember
ministers have to take into account many
other factors there's the health of the
economy it's the mental health of the
country there's also um the fact that
you know are these going to be effective
and are they going to be listened to
will people just break them anyway and i
think professor chris whittie um spoke
at the select committee last week and he
said look ultimately these are very
difficult decisions to make and it's up
to politicians to make them it's not
scientific advice to say what should or
shouldn't be done here and you know you
had that meeting today with the prime
minister with professor witte and sir
patrick valens the chief scientific
officer and i'm sure if they felt
restrictions had to come in then they
would have done so i think lucy did
touch on a very interesting point here
which is that in the past the government
has gone for quite heavy-handed measures
on this stuff we've had three lockdowns
we've had tiering systems regional
restrictions you name it we've tried
them all in this country this time they
have very much shifted it and in terms
of potentially overreacting they are
very much under reacting and the bet is
that the the modeling is off and so far
some of the modelling does seem to have
been a bit of miss in terms of the
severity of omnicolon how it's leading
to hospitalizations but it is such a big
gamble at the moment and i think really
in a month's time we could look back and
say boris johnson hasn't he been lucky
hasn't this paid off well for him or
could look back and say okay he's really
blown it and that will then go on top of
all his other political troubles
yes and lucy to the the mail which is
very much of the school of thought
parties get the go-ahead but will it be
party now and pay for it later
well possibly it's a brilliant upbeat
tone the mail has taken as you say but i
do think we have to remember what sajid
javed has warned today is for people to
continue to wear masks to celebrate with
the windows open where possible to take
a test before going out and with this
sort of general message of caution it's
not a free-for-all for everyone to go
wild and forget that we are still in the
midst of the pandemic so i think the
messaging that the government is trying
to put out is still is still one very
much one of wariness um but clearly
people are happy uh sebastian pointed
out you know the economy is a major
factor in all this already people have
been um self-locking down much of
december i know i wanted to be with my
family and so didn't want to risk
catching covid by going out to other
social events many other people felt the
same and so one frequenting bars
restaurants and other venues which they
ordinarily would be in december so i
think it's really good news for all
those venues that we'll be able to bring
in punters on new year's eve and try and
claw back some revenue yes
let's hope so sebastian lucy for the
moment thank you